pleased to have chris collinsworth back
on here how are you doing chris
i'm good rich can we rewind just a bit
the end with you and dan
you're gonna take off and all that stuff
can we just do that for clarification
sure
what taking off shirts and pants and
things of that nature is that what
you're saying
uh apparently do we what what happened
you guys took your shirts off one time
uh at the all-star game i don't know if
by the way chris you didn't really want
to know right you just use that it's
just a
something humorous maybe to start our
interview is that the way that it works
no i really don't care
[Laughter]
see i knew that i i see i i knew that i
i sensed it and yeah you know i didn't
want you to go down that road if chris
didn't really tweet at you about it
chris there you go yeah at uh at uh at
collinsworth pff right that's the way we
work correct
okay very good
what what number super bowl is this for
you broadcasting
chris what number is that um the the
copy and the coloring unless this is the
fifth and this is the first one without
tom brady and bill belichick is that
right
no kenny she's your first if i'm not
mistaken were you in the booth with fox
for eagles and and patriots right i
remember that one correct
the coldest day in the history of
jacksonville yes we were there i
remember that that was our first that
was our first full year of nfl network
covering something from start to finish
because we came on the year the year
before and it was patriots and um
and uh panthers and then the the the
patriots completed the back to back
right there in jacksonville so that was
one for you this is downfall it's really
amazing when you think about it and now
you know tom announcing his retirement
and it's just
the whole full circle part of it and we
actually did
the last game in tampa and
didn't didn't know it you know nobody
knew it at the time so
um
yeah it's amazing and now
now here come the cincinnati bengals to
take their place so
how do you figure that that is pretty
amazing no question about that chris
collinsworth here on the rich eisen show
netsuite by oracle is a sponsor of the
rich eisen show if you're ready to
upgrade go to netsuite.com rich our
terrestrial radio audience is back here
and chris collinsworth is on the rich
eisen show so chris how wild is it for
you
that you're calling a super bowl and the
cincinnati bengals are in it
walk me through that one up for you
bizarre on every level on every level i
i can remember watching
uh the evan mcpherson kick go through
and going oh my goodness
i am gonna be calling a cincinnati
bengals
super bowl and you know and you know
what goes with that too right you know
you're going to get oh he's so biased
for or why does he hate the bengals and
you know it's going to be one of those
kinds of days
but i'm still so excited to be there i i
would have bought a ticket i would have
paid any amount of money to have a
ticket to go watch this game and and i
get to sit in the best seat in the house
and and next to al and just enjoy it so
um
you know
it's it's a little daunting in that you
know
you you gotta call it you know you gotta
don't think a lot between what you see
and what you say
and
there'll be some wounded feelings at the
end of it i'm sure
um but i'm i'm really excited i'm happy
for the franchise it's been a long time
um
but mostly i'm happy for the the city of
cincinnati you know i mean when a
midwestern city gets a super bowl
and the world's attention comes down on
a place like cincinnati or kansas city
or
at indianapolis or whatever you want to
say
you know it it's just different i mean
in la
it's great they're excited
but the grammys are coming up or the
academy awards are coming up or the
lakers are coming up and yet for the
city of cincinnati it is just
all-encompassing the city is
orange and all the buildings are lit up
here and it's there's just a real
collective excitement going on and the
interesting thing is uh i'm just going
through my head here because the bengals
are usually the team you flex out of
um when was the last time you called a
bengals game chris it has been a while i
was trying to figure that out as well
um and i i maybe 17 something like that
maybe rich the strangest thing is
because we've done what i think three
rams games this year uh including the
playoff win over tampa but how much more
i knew about the rams
than i knew about the bengals you know
i'm always i've got the the bengals game
on and you know it's one of many that
i'm trying to watch because you're also
trying to watch you know whatever the
big game is and you're trying to watch
whichever teams you're going to do next
week and you know you get all that going
on on a sunday afternoon
but
on monday
of last week i said i'm just going to
start from scratch i literally went
through every one of their games i
watched
all the defensive guys i watched all the
offensive throws and
and and plays that joe burrow and these
receivers had made and i but it was
enlightening for me to see
just how exciting this team is
i mean these are playmakers if we come
out of this game
and the bengals have won the football
game
they are the new kansas city chiefs i
mean they just are these are play makers
that make exciting plays that have a
young quarterback that have that are the
new darlings of the nfl if they lose
they're an up-and-coming team and it's
great and the rams deserve it and all
that sort of stuff but if the bengals
win
that's quite the story well if the
bengals win then then joe burrow as
maybe the next brady will really leave
the station because of year two and how
talented he is and how
his career has begun or an ascendancy
similar to kurt warner's and i know that
that's in theaters near you right now
but i mean kid from athens ohio who gets
his shot in lsu has one of the greatest
seasons if not the greatest season in
the history of college quarterbacking
first overall pick that nobody saw
coming right until he had that season in
lsu and then two years later he wins the
super bowl for the bengals i don't i
can't i don't know how you can compare
that ascendancy with anybody and that is
on the line on sunday when you're
broadcasting the other thing that's kind
of fun about it is
that
he couldn't even get on the field at
ohio state right i mean that's step one
when he first went to lsu is like okay
whatever
and then it just took off and and it's
so amazing that a team that
admittedly i mean they'll openly talk
about that we knew we needed offensive
line help here and yet maybe because of
the relationship maybe because they're
trying to build around the quarterback
who knows but joe burrow clearly wanted
his guy
uh that i mean he lit the world on fire
with jamar chase i mean they were just a
dominant team in the dominant conference
of the sec
uh maybe one of the best college
football teams we've ever seen
and and now they're coming to the nfl
and it's almost like well we won in high
school we won in college i won the eisen
trophy why wouldn't i win the super bowl
it's really my second year oh by the way
coming off of
major majors right knee reconstruction
and
some of my runs were the biggest plays
in the game in the championship game
chris collinsworth here on the rich
eisen show um you know all that said as
we've just said about joe burrow
uh aaron donald von miller leonard floyd
rest of this defense can make
joe's nine sack win over tennessee like
a day at the beach right like a pillow
fight i would imagine how do you see
this
playing out that dynamic on sunday chris
i mean that's it i i think that's it uh
in a nutshell and maybe to narrow it
down even a little bit more the right
guard position
uh akima dinergy and jackson carmen
rotated in there at the right guard
position isaiah prince filling in for
riley wreath really did a pretty good
job
in the game but you know the rams and
what they like to do with some of those
overload looks
really is going to put a lot of pressure
on either guard so
you'll see von miller out wide you'll
see aaron donald out
basically looking like a defensive end
and then you'll see greg gaines to that
same side but what that does is it holds
that center in place there
and then you've got aaron donald with
about a five yard run at your guard and
you've got bond miller with about a five
yard run at your tackle
so as a quarterback you better get that
thing out of there about as quickly as
you possibly can
because even if they just go straight
bull rush we've seen time after time
those two guys have the ability to
basically throw your offensive linemen
at the quarterback
that's basically it right i mean
obviously stafford the crazy thing is
see how well he has been pleasing and i
don't mean that by crazy i'm just saying
that the the narrative about when he was
acquired by the rams from detroit was
can he do it you know we've never seen
him do it is it the lions is it him is
it a combination of both
and he's you know completely fripped
flipped his his playoff record from owen
3 now to this year 3-0
and even in that crazy game in tampa if
i told you there would be four turnovers
by the rams on that day you know many
people would say well how many by
stafford he made every play including
the throw to cup
at the end after it seemed that all was
now tied but potentially lost he's been
remarkable
these playoffs yeah chris on the love of
the game pass right because cooper cup
is just the clear out guy
uh but with the tampa buccaneers you
know there's a good chance that todd
bowles are going to throw a blitz at you
at any given time and yet there they
were and that pass
was incredible i mean it was incredible
you are under the ultimate pressure uh
tom brady has just brought his team all
the way back were we looking at the
atlanta falcons kind of come back one
more time here
uh for this team to go on to the
championship game
and yet here they are basically getting
the ball with under a minute whatever it
was 40 seconds and two passes
to
cooper cub down the field kick the game
winner and walk off
that was the heck of a statement right
there i mean it really was because when
that momentum shifts like that the way
that it did on kansas city in that game
a week ago it is hard
to get it back together it is just hard
and with two throws matthew stafford did
what everybody was questioning whether
or not he could do and how about tom
brady's last snap of his career as a
touchdown handoff to uh
leonard fournette i mean who the hell
knew at the time right did you get any
sense talking to him that week that this
might be it thinking about it anything
like that any indication different from
any of the times you sat down with brady
or talked to him zoomed with him prior
to this game
chris not not the
not what he said there was a little bit
of what he said
but there was a little
swirl you know what i mean there was
just a little swirl okay that
this was a little bit different
um and you know i can't help but think
rich you mean you tell me you know this
league as well as i do
you know if chris godwin is still
playing if antonio brown doesn't do the
striptease
does you know
is this team still
in the super bowl i don't know you know
because that was a very close margin of
error there uh and tristan wurst warren
was a plan at the right tackle position
arguably their best offense of lyman
so some unfortunate things down the
stretch and yet there was tom one more
time making that
monster comeback which we i mean it's
almost
getting to the point in these playoffs
where you expect it like what lead is
safe now in these crazy playoffs it has
just been it's been otherworldly
well have a great time calling it man
you know the building obviously very
well uh you know i i don't know it's
going to be super bowl it's going to be
in control of the game so i don't know
if al's going to miss the who's house
chance i know he loves that
the whole day um especially when
pre-game warm-up that's really good yeah
oh my gosh al's on tomorrow show the uh
national treasure that is al michaels uh
have a great time calling the game man
and again it's just
it's pretty cool right like i guess i i
honestly thought when when the bengals
made it that that was it for the rams
because i thought the bengals had to
face the 49ers in the super bowl right
i did i was like this is not happening
it
it
was
happening and then they you know the
niners had the big lead too i was like
oh my gosh
right you'd see all that coming back at
you and i'm sure they've got everything
set up with your records and jamar
chases for for the broadcast i can't
wait to see all that yeah there's
there's that was so funny mike brown hit
me with that the other day about what
great receivers we've had in cincinnati
and da da da da da go mike just stop it
this kid is off the charts
don't compare him to anybody that we had
on our team this kid is just different
he's phenomenal i really can't wait to
watch him play in person chris i can't
wait for you calling it uh thanks for
the time enjoy the week we'll see you
out here in l.a man thanks for the call
you're the best that's chris
collinsworth he literally is the best um
right here on the rich housing show hey
you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here